queen yeah magnus is going for it the
king's going to continue advancing
okay no he doesn't no but he's this is a
blunder oh magnus has blundered away his
advantage
this is unbelievable yeah he just walked
into a double attack
simple check white's king will move and
then the white pawn white's
only winning hope is going to drop off
the board
white's extra pawn is gone now on that b
line it's
three pawns against three pawns easy
draw for black totally
you spotted it quicker than magnus did
there jovanka
but it's been there in the air for a
long long time
oh my god i wanted to give up a pawn to
get that a trade but uh
okay well yeah magnus just
blundering away his victory and you
could just see his reaction
he literally jumped up on his chair he
couldn't believe that he did this and
okay there is still now some small hope
and that is that potentially you can
create a pass pawn on the right side
it's pretty far advanced i mean i know
black should be easily able to handle it
but
you never know yep and maybe if white
can
get a queen trade in favorable
circumstances then the white king's
slightly more active than the black king
the white king is going to be able to
run towards the center run towards the
pawns quicker but after that pawn trade
black's king
kind of hides out yeah there's no real
chance here the problem is white's
king's too open and now there are lots
of checks now you can't rely on
you have no past pawns that can easily
run through white's only past pawn is
easily
located by the black king so magnus
he'll try but aronian
two versus two on the same side it
should be a simple draw